hi everyone and welcome back to our 10th
lecture on reinforcement learning today
we're going to be talking a lot more
about approximate dynamic programming
and the frame the algorithm that you've
seen in the
last few lectures especially in model 3
reinforcement learning in terms of this
paradigm
so let's dig in
so last lectures
you've already seen mdps dynamic
programming we touched a bit about
uh approximate dynamic programming
mostly as a framework
to to guide you through the model 3 and
model
model-free prediction and model-free
control
we've also seen a bit
far back belmont equations and their
corresponding operators we're going to
be reusing these concepts today and
we touched upon
with hado on
reinforcement learning under function
approximation and we'll see a bit more
of that in the next lectures with mateo
on
a particular deep reinforcement learning
now this lecture we're going to be
revisiting the proxima dynamic
programming and under these two sources
of error estimation so uh not having
access to the true model and being
being forced in a sense to sample from
from the model through experience
paired with function approximation which
means that we are not in a tabular
setting anymore we can't represent the
value functions exactly
for all states in action but we would
use a function approximator to to do
that
okay
and as i um already mentioned in the
next lectures you're going to see more
of these paradigms
and most of the state-of-the-art
research kind of falls within this
paradigm
and
in in particular
removing the perfect uh
knowledge of the environment assumption
and going more towards a popular
version of function approximation which
is deep neural networks
a couple of preliminaries
this have been introduced before but
just to
to recap and be on the same side uh
we've introduced previously the belmont
optimality operator this was derived
from the
bellman
optimality equation
and the definition is in in equation 1
here
to note that this bellman operator
has a unique fixed point
which is exactly the value function that
we are looking for that's why iterating
this operator will eventually get us to
the optimal value function this is under
you know no approximation condition with
perfect
knowledge of the the model so this is
just pure dynamic
programming okay
and then we had the the belmont
expectation uh operator
which has similar uh properties it's a
contraction it has one unique fixed
point but the unique fixed point of this
operator is the
um evaluation of the policy pi uh
for for which this operator is
defined
okay
good and uh
just uh another reminder dynamic
programming through the lens of these
operators uh the two popular algorithms
there that we've seen are value
iteration and policy iteration and
you've seen approximate versions of this
for instance q learning being an
approximate version of a value iteration
so these
both of these say
value iteration is just applying
multiple times the belmont optimality
operator and again under perfect
conditions no approximation
this is guaranteed to converge to the
fixed point of this this operator
t star which is the optimal batman
operator which is the optimal value
function and policy iteration was this
procedure of starting with a particular
policy doing policy evaluation which can
be done iteratively via the the bellman
expectation
operator or can be done in any other way
especially if uh
we can solve the the true system of
equations and then on top of these uh
this evaluation we're going to do an
improvement step usually greedy
improvement step and if we've seen in
previous lectures that that is
guaranteed to give us a better policy
than the one we've just evaluated and we
just iterated this process
by improving greedily on these uh this
evaluation and at least in finite cases
this will will eventually because we're
improving the the policy at the age
point in time this will eventually get
us to the optimal policy
good
okay
so uh
now approximate dynamic programming as
you've
seen before
uh removes a couple of the the
assumption of the
of the true and of knowing the
underlying mdp and being able to to
represent exactly the value function so
moving away from tabular and moving away
from the
the assumption that we can uh actually
evaluate perfectly the expectations
needed in these in these updates
okay and by doing so
in one of the cases where we don't know
the underlying mdp we're going to be
introducing some sampling or estimation
error because we're trying to
estimate an expectation via samples
and in the other
uh case we're going to be introducing
some kind of approximation error because
we're not we might not be able to
represent exactly
in the parametric
function class we've
we've chosen the true value functions
that
that we want to estimate at each
point of this process
all of these procedures are kind of
iterative procedures so we'll have a lot
of value functions uh in between value
functions that we would need to estimate
so whenever
neither of like any of these functions
cannot fully be
approximated by the approximation
uh
by the
parametric class we've chosen then we
incur some error at that iteration so
it's not only that the true solution
can't be represented it might be that
the true solution is representable but
the intermediate uh steps in the the
intermediate value functions that that
we're trying to approximate are not
representable under the
parametric class then we'll still
going to incur some approximation error
okay
and of course
as as always the even under these
conditions the
the objective of
of rl is to come up with a policy that
is
hopefully close to optimal behavior
okay
so let's uh let's look more in depth at
the
approximate value function uh value
iteration uh paradigm so this is this is
close to what you've seen for instance
in in q learning
so again as a reminder just this is this
is value iteration through the lens of
the belmont optimality operator so we
started with the value
and at each iteration k we update uh vk
plus 1 towards or in in the exact case
with the
one step
application of the belmont optimality
operator
applied to
the value function at the previous
iteration
okay and iterating this as k tends to
infinity
this
the sequence of value function
eventually converges under the infinity
norm to v star
if this is still not uh clear to you i
would urge you to to go back to our
second lecture on dynamic programming
and uh see the arguments there
okay
now the approximate version of this
is basically we're gonna do this this
iterative step at each iteration k
approximately so that's that's what this
a
stands for and again this approximation
can be based on the function
approximation or based on the fact that
we
we actually don't have access to a t
star
and we'll we'll have to sample to
approximate it
and the same as as before we're gonna do
a greedy improve one step
uh on the one whatever
uh value function we approximated here
okay
now the the question that the rises of
course is
if we iterate this process
would we converge to the optimal value
function we converge at all
um and in general that's that's that's a
no it highly depends on what the
approximation here is
okay
um
the nice things that that we
kind of hinted last time is that even if
we don't converge all the way to the
optimal value function we are actually
interested only in the
uh quality of the policy this derived
greedy policy with respect to the
estimate at one point in this iteration
we're never gonna do this iteration
forever
um and
we're we're trying to understand how
good that that policy is
okay
um and just uh
just to be clear
usually we would be using something like
the q version of uh approximate value
iteration
where
we do exactly the same process but not
for v but for q
again start with uh with an arbitrary
value function q zero
update
uh towards
the
uh one step bellman operator with
respect to
uh qk
at iteration k plus one and then return
as a control policy the greedy with
respect to to that estimate
this is this is what we use usually in
practice especially if we don't have a
model because remember that to derive
this greedy policy we actually need the
action value function
uh to just
basically pick the the the arc max of
the
q value function if we don't and we have
only v then we would have to have at
least
a one-step model
in order to to derive the greedy policy
so usually we're just gonna uh go for
approximating the the q value
okay
and as i hinted uh before
we really want to be able to say
something
about the quality
of this
greedy policy
derived after n steps
of uh iterating this
approximate value iteration process
and this is what the the following
theorem is saying this is um an old
result from 96
but
still a very important result in the in
the field that basically
does this for us so
we're going to bound under the infinity
norm the performance of the policy
uh at
the end
iteration of this
value iteration
procedure
with respect to the optimal value
function
so that's what this uh
first term says
and this
is
gonna be uh bounded by two factors
first the initial error
this is uh
uh basically defined in the in the
second line here is how far is my
um
initial initialization
with respect to the optimal value
function with respect to the l infinity
norm so this is
this is the second term in the bound
okay and the the first term here
is the approximation error that i'm
gonna incur
at iteration k
okay
so
usually at the iteration k plus one
i'm gonna try to estimate
i'm gonna try to uh
back up
d star
q
uh
okay
but because i'm in a an approximate
setting what i'm actually gonna be uh my
my next q
k plus 1 would actually be a
uh t star
qk
so
this is this accounts for how much error
am i incurring
by introducing this a
in my backups
in the in the value iteration
okay so this this should be kind of
intuitive outside the you know the the
terms uh in front that uh our
performance of the policy
after and and iterations of this value
iteration is bounded
by
um both
where we started so our initial error
and the the approximate error that we're
gonna be incurring
at each iteration
cool
so um next we're gonna move into the the
proof of the statement
okay
let's start by first denoting
the maximum error
that we can incur up to iteration n so
for any iteration a k in between that
and
n
we are maximizing over the approximation
error this is again for usually for
dynamic programming this would be
um
qk plus one
but in approximate dynamic programming
we're introducing approximation so
this instead this term will be
our
value function at the iteration k plus
1.
so discrepancy between
um
this k plus 1 and this k plus 1 is what
the approximation error introduces okay
so we're gonna now maximize
over all of these errors and denote that
by
uh epsilon
okay
next the the first thing we're going to
do is try to
relate
the
value function at iteration k plus 1
and in particular at iteration n
with respects to the optimal value
function
note that this is not exactly what we
want uh
the statement of the the theorem is
actually saying something stronger in
terms of the performance of the policy
derived based on the estimate
um at the iteration
n so if we have
q
n then this induces
uh via greedy
this policy q n
it's greedy
with respect to the estimate that we had
at iteration n and we're interested
really in the in the value of that
policy
okay
but we'll we'll see that this is really
um simple based on the result that we've
had
um in the last lecture on dynamic
programming where
uh we
we
have a result that relates the
performance of greedy policy
uh with respect to the value function
that induces that that policy we're
going to just revise that that result in
the in the next slide but
first um let's let's look at this this
equation
okay
and uh we're going gonna break it down
into a couple of terms so
first we
um
add and subtract the same term
and due to the triangle inequality we
can
we can split these apart
this is an
upper bound to
the left hand side
okay and then note that
this term
is exactly
the approximation error at iteration k
which is upper bounded by definition
by this
epsilon which maximizes over all the
iteration up to n okay so that's that's
why we get uh this term
being less than equal
then
epsilon
and then
on the the first term there we are using
uh that the
amount operator has a unique fixed point
which is q star
so
uh
just as a reminder
that means that
this holds
um
again because q star is the unique fixed
point of this operator
and then we're going to be using the
fact that
this operator
q star is a contraction
contraction
actually it's a gamma contraction
which means that
less than equal then gamma
so the
um
so this term now is less than equal than
this term
okay
and now what we've
actually achieved is a recurrence
relationship between
uh how far
the value function at iteration k plus 1
is
related to how far it was at the
previous iteration qk
okay
and what we're gonna do
um now is basically unfold the data that
equation
so this is the equation that that we're
gonna like the inequality that we're
gonna be using
and we're gonna apply it
uh
at previous iterations so uh first
for
k
and we're going to relate it to k minus
1 then k minus 1 to k minus 2 and so on
so forth
and what we get is
we can relate this to the initial error
at iteration
k equals zero
um
and
this term which is the
discounted errors it's an upper bound
actually of the discounted errors that
we've encountered at each iteration
and this is
of course uh
also less than equal then if this would
have been uh you know
k equals
capital k actually goes to infinity so
this now is upper bounded by
um
the mistake or
the um how good our initialization was
and
this uh this term accounting for the
errors that we've uh
we've seen it's actually an upper bound
on the errors that we've seen throughout
this approximation at every
iteration k
okay
now
uh i'm just restating this
here
it's the same equation as as here
and now the the last step
is to
relate
apologies for the buzzer there
but as as i was saying we're gonna now
relate to this result
to the performance of the policy induced
by the estimate at iteration k or
iteration n so just as a reminder
the policy that we're deriving is greedy
with respect to that estimate and we are
interested in evaluating
the that policy at iteration n
and for that we're going to be using the
result we had in our um
last lecture on dynamic programming
which was the performance of the greedy
policy
based on
an arbitrary value function qk
and that if you remember this
was
the performance of the derived policy
q pi k
can be bounded in terms of the
performance of
uh how
far
this estimate on which we're basing the
greedy on is with respect to the optimal
value function
okay
and note that we already have this term
upper bounded here
and just by
plugging in 10 into equation 11
you get exactly the statement of the
theory
okay now that we've proven the statement
of the theorem let's look at
some of the implications that this has
and first we're going to look at the
last term there
so some of the implications are
as
n tends to infinity
this term in red
tends to zero as
um
this uh
gamma to the n
decays exponentially passed
so what that means is that although uh
at each iteration n this this term
appears and is is bounding our
performance with respect to the
the initial point
our initialization of this
this process
as n tends to infinity basically this
term will disappear which is good news
which means that um
in the limit we will have no um
dependence on the initialization point
okay
um another question uh here just as
maybe as a sanity check
um
is
what if we do initialize you know by
chance at exactly the
uh optimal point
at q star
well let's say what the
the bound says so obviously this uh the
second term goes away because the
norm there
uh of the initial error is zero
but uh you can see that we are left with
uh another term here
which is still the maximization of all
the approximation error that we would
encounter
uh in
in each iteration
okay
um
[Music]
now the question becomes would that be
would that be zero in general
let's uh let's consider just one
iteration of this process so let's say
at
we start at
q star as
our first
iteration of this process
so q zero is q star
and our first iteration of this
approximate value iteration process
gets us q1 which is the approximate
version of the one step application of
the belmont operator
to q0
because q0 is q star then the
application of the belmont
operator
2
q star is q star
so um q1
is actually
the approximation
operator applied to q star
now in general
this might not be zero so for instance
if
a is
um an approximate of
a
hypothesis space let's say
that is not within our class of
approximations
then this um this error at the first
iteration might not be by might not be
zero so even initializing at the
um right solution in the sense
by approximation we might move away from
from this solution
that being said if uh if this initial
point has to be in the
uh function of approximations
then uh
this
has to be zero because the the
projection here
just just in in terms of coming back
into the the class of functions
uh this would be like
not lossy
so the the projection of
q star
under the function approximation
um would just give you back the
q star because that's the closest point
in the function approximation
uh again if if a is
something like an estimation error
where
instead of having the true belmont
operator we have
a sampled version of this again this
error
add the first iteration might be
non-zero
probably will be non-zero which means
that even
um if we initialize at the right
solution we might move away and once we
move away from the the solution we can
further move away and so on so forth
so this this
result is very general
but it does a state that even if we are
close enough to the solution
it highly depends on
what the approximation errors incurred
that if each iteration will do
and how much we could in principle lose
based on that
okay
now uh let's focus a bit on the the
other term
we've seen already that as n tends to
infinity the second term goes to zero
which means we wash out the initial
approximation error
now let's um
consider a hypothesis space uh f so this
this is where um let's say our
approximation comes from
and uh let's now have
uh a be exactly the projection
uh with respect to the l infinity norm
okay so this is uh the definition of
this projection is uh
uh
is now in the
uh in the equation
below
so we're just looking
for
um
for the projection of g a function
or vector
uh under the l infinity is trying to
find
in the space of value function f
the closest point
to g
under the l infinity north
okay
now if we do that then the
approximate
value iteration algorithm
uh at each iteration k plus 1
tries to
will uh take the form of uh applying the
the bellman operator
to
optimality operator to the previous
value function and then projecting it
via this this operator
now
the the thing to note here is that this
combine operator
uh the approximation just via the
projection we're still doing
full dynamic programming in terms of uh
using the the expectation using the true
model here
so this combined operator is
is indeed a contraction
operator in l infinity because basically
t star is a contraction with respect to
l infinity and
the projection with respect to that norm
is a non-expansional mapping so the full
thing is a contraction with the same
gamma parameter
because this whole operator is a
contraction this algorithm does converge
is guaranteed to converge to a fixed
point actually because it's a
contraction
from uh from previous the
banana fix point theorem
it has one unique fixed point it says
a fixed point uh and this is unique
that has this uh this equation
and
as before
if
q star the thing that we're looking
is
uh indeed in f is under our functional
class then uh the above algorithm this
this uh
this iteration in uh in red
actually converges
to the to the true value function and
this is this is uh easy to to see if
we again
remember
that
uh
this algorithm
has one unique fixed point and you can
you can plug in in this equation if f
equals
uh
the projection
uh via the l infinity norm uh t star f
and see that q star actually satisfies
this this equation
so now we've got at least on the
function approximator still full full
model of the mdp a converging algorithm
that at least if
you know the the true value function the
one that we're looking for the optimal
value function is representable in our
functional class
then we are guaranteed to to converge
there
even if it's not in our
if q star is not in that function across
this algorithm still converges
it just might not be to to q star
because you know as as we've
established q star is not representable
enough so we we can't hope to recover
something uh we can't recover q star via
this parameterization
okay
let's look now at some concrete
instances of
this paradigm and um
uh although i have just proposed a
convergent algorithm we'll see that this
algorithm is
somewhat impractical and we're gonna
try to fix that and we'll see that
uh trying to fix that actually gives us
some of the popular algorithms that that
you've seen before and that are now used
in the in the literature
okay
so um let's first have a you know um
clear instantiation of the algorithm
that we've just proposed so at each
iteration k we're trying to
uh approximate uh the
the one step bellman operator
by projecting back
with respect to the an infinity norm
under some hypothesis class f
now for
uh concreteness we're gonna consider
uh f to be
the the space of all um linear functions
with respect to some
feature space phi
so all of the the functions
all of the q
k
in all of these iterations will have to
be represented
or approximated
in this in this functional class okay
and then uh
doing that we obtain
this
simplify the algorithm
at iteration k plus 1 we're looking
in the space of
linear value functions of the point that
best approximates under the l infinity
norm
t star
q k
and because
we have only you know one set of
parameters which is
w the weight of this
feature vector the
equation 12 can be reinterpreted as just
finding
at each duration k or k plus one
a weight vector k plus 1 that that
minimizes this this equation
now
um
how would you solve this this equation
how how tractable is this even under a
very you know
one of the simplest hypothesis classes
uh out there
now here are um
a couple of potential problems but
before before i flash that uh just just
try to take a moment here and
try to think how you would find this
vector
um wk plus one at each duration and how
how hard
or how easy would
uh
that update look like or what's the
complexity of that that update how would
you do it for you know a linear
class
or something like a neural network or
any kind of other function approximator
class there
okay hopefully you've
uh you've at least tried this mental
exercise and
see that this is not trivial
um
and there are basically two problems
there one is that the
l infinity minimization is typically
hard to be carried out
usually we are
using different norms
more prominently
something like l2
that is very well behaved
and easy to to optimize in the linear
case this has a you know um
closed form solution
uh l infinity is is
is usually a much harder optimization
problem
and
as you've seen in the the previous
lectures and this is the general
assumption i guess in reinforcement
learning is that
t-star is typically unknown and has to
be approximated somehow usually from
samples
so
um here are some proposals of easing
these problems so first i just hinted at
this that instead of fel infinity we're
just gonna replace that with something
like l2 that is much easier to
uh to optimize so instead of having now
the l infinity optimization there we're
gonna
do the same thing but find in um find
the point in f that is closest to
um
t star q
uh k
with respect to
an l to norm or an l to norm with
respect to some probability uh
distribution mu
okay
and hopefully you you
know how to solve this um any any kind
of like um
squared regression kind of thing will
tackle that so uh in most cases this
will have both uh at least for the
linear case a fixed
like tractable form
and if not in most of the other cases we
can do something like back prop and just
take gradients with respect to this this
loss
and
you've already seen you know in the
lectures in model free control and
variants of that that
in order to approximate the star we're
just gonna sample
and uh
usually we have this
tuples of s a
our
next state that we're going to sample
with respect to this distribution with
respect to that norm and our transition
model and we're going to
approximate
this term t t star q
q k
by
this
y t target for each sample
and this is just again
the true
uh operator the true uh
q uh
d star would be just expectation
of uh yt
for all the the samples um sd 80 uh rt
plus one st plus one
okay so now uh what we get is that at
each iteration
we're gonna find in our
um
hypothesis space f
q
uh w this these are the parameters of
the our function approximator we're
still we're still using
a linear function class
that minimizes the square loss
and this is now a sample square loss
rather than
the
the true
expectation loss
okay
so this is just
re
uh stating what the what the last
equation was and um
just uh
uh reinterpreting yt
as
an approximate approximation an
approximate application of the belmont
optimality operator
to the previous uh value function at the
iteration key
and this actually is a very
general
recipe for coming up with
a fitted q iteration kind of algorithms
or just
simple
cube based uh
q learning based uh algorithms
uh and
there are a couple of dimensions there
that we can vary
one i've um really never used that we're
using here
linear parametrization
so this can be done with any kind of
functional class f that can be
parameterized by
as we did here with uh linear uh
function classes with neural networks
kernels whatever your you know
parametrization of your regressor is
anything can can go in there
so these these are the you know the
parametric class that we're gonna be
approximating the intermediate value
functions with
now um there's there's a couple of other
dimensions that we can vary
the other one is again we're gonna be uh
approximating
uh
t star the the application of this
operator and in order to do that we're
gonna have to sample somehow and this
can be done online can be done from a
fixed predefined or pre
um
you know a given kind of data set uh
someone you know
gets you some data
um some previous
intervention protocols some
previous behaviors of policies that have
been used in uh regulating
the
power plant or something like that and
those are like you know just a fixed
data set
um you can also have a replay kind of uh
model or a replay memory or a generative
model where you can sample from this
model to generate those uh those samples
so all of these are you know
a way of approximating that operator via
samples
but how you generate the samples and
where they come from it's um you know
it's a free dimension in a sense
and the the last dimension there that is
free also uh
has to do with
uh how we approximate the um
this one step bellman operator and the
the
the simplest one is the
one we've used before this is basically
q learning
uh the the other instantiation the
second instantiation there is in instead
of this uh
um
this the
the application to
the
previous
estimate we uh we have something like a
target network that that we keep fixed
it's almost like saying um we
at one point uh decide that iteration k
is uh the target network that we saved
and we're gonna keep that for a while
and make estimates
uh and updates and when we change the
target network again we're gonna call
that iteration k plus one
and there are multiple other versions of
this
this target
that can be done via off policy learning
and multi-step operators where
we can get
not
a one-step estimate
of this operator but maybe multiple
steps uh estimate to um
to speed up the credit assignment
and you're gonna see that
in the next lecture with the with hana
both of these uh both of these variants
but again this is a very general recipe
and there are as i said like these these
three dimensions you can
pretty much mix and match
so let's look at one particular
instantiation of this recipe which is
dqn
i'm sure you've seen this before or at
least you've looked at the paper and the
dqn is one of these algorithms that that
does follow this to this recipe and
in particular for the approximation
class we chose neural networks uh the
samples are sampled from a replay
and the um
the target
here
in the regression is based on a target
network
okay
now um here's another instantiation of
this which is bachara
where um we can't interact necessarily
with the environment is the um
examples i mentioned before that
maybe someone hands you in some data
that has been collected under some
policies
or under human interventions or any any
kind of other uh data set
and you wanna
still make use of that so the function
approximator there can be whatever is
appropriate for the
size of data or the you know the the
problem specification the observation um
set
and then we are working with the fixed
data set and let's say a
a
option here for instantiation is uh is
just the one step
uh
approximation of the belmont operator
via one sample
which is uh which is what uh the first
line here uh says this is probably the
the first thing that that i would try
but of course like uh you can have
something like just
more generally off policy updates um
because the data set is uh is fixed and
you didn't have necessarily access to
the policy that
generated that data set this might be
hard so q learning so the the first
version there this one is uh probably
the easiest
uh if you do have access basically to
the collection policy then you can do
something more fancy in terms of policy
updates but again in both of these
examples i'm kind of assuming that the
data set that you are given is not the
current policy that you're trying to
evaluate so this will be off policy
most of time if not all of the time i
mean for the control problem we will
always be off policy because the data
set was collected under a particular
policy
versus
now at each iteration we're changing the
policy
okay
and
another example here is what you've seen
in the last lecture which is something
like dinah again we can choose whatever
approximation family we choose to
and this is um
okay this is a mistake it should be
samples are both online and from a
replay
model
and the
the simplest instantiation of dyna will
choose to do
something like q learning which is the
one
sample instantiation of this this
operator
okay
that's it for uh approximate
value iteration
next we're gonna be looking at
approximate policy iteration the other
uh algorithm for for using for doing
control
this is a much um
less studied i guess or less popular
paradigm but it's uh it's good to
uh to go through it because there are
many algorithms these days that do
follow that but most of the algorithms
that will
you will encounter in control especially
for off policy uh
actually followed the the this this kind
of uh recipe a fitted queue iteration
with
one of these dimensions varying or an
instantiation of one of these dimensions
we start with a reminder of the policy
iteration paradigm
this again
is the iterative procedure where we
start with the policy
at um
at the initialization and we iterate
this process of policy evaluation and uh
policy improvement in our case greeting
improvement
so at each point in time we are
evaluating the the policy
derived at the previous step and we make
a gratification step with respect to
that and we know that at least in finite
cases this will converge to the optimal
policy
now the approximate setting
uh actually the approximation incurs in
this policy evaluation step only
and now the value we derived at or our
approximation at iteration i
is the one that will provide uh the
argument for the gratification so
instead of
doing a gratification with respect to
the actual evaluation of our previous
policy we're going to do a gratification
with respect to the approximation to
that evaluation problem
as hinted before
this
usually does not converge to the optimal
value function
but um nevertheless what what we're
really interested in is the quality of
the policy that we're gonna get after
let's say iteration k
in this
particular
notation iteration i so in general we're
interested in the quality of the policy
pi i
uh as determined
by q pi i
uh with respect to
let's say the the optimal value function
so how how good is that the policy after
um i iterations of this this procedure
and this is exactly what the
the next result uh we're gonna look at
um quantifies
so considering an mdp and the cube um
qk and
pi k are the
um
value function
uh
at iteration k and the the gratification
uh at iteration k minus one
then we
we have the following statement
so
we can bound the
quality of
the policy at time
at the iteration k
by
the
approximations errors that we've
incurred uh up to that up to that point
uh actually it's a it's a much stronger
statement than this is
saying the the
in the limit the limb sup of this error
so your
error with respect to the value function
is upper bounded by
the
the last errors like the convergence of
this approximation errors as you
approach uh convergence
okay
um
we're gonna try to prove this uh but
first some notation um
i think
first of all this should be a uh
somewhat intuitive statement uh the same
as before we're gonna
the quality of the policy that you're
gonna get after k iteration is uh
bounded by the
the errors we're making in this
approximation but this is actually a
stronger result as i said
as these things uh the approximation
errors
might still converge uh in the limit or
at least they are bounded which means
that this um
this term
is also bounded and will converge at
least in within that bound so it might
oscillate around a fixed point but it is
it is bounded by the
um
by how much the
approximation errors vary in the limit
okay
so a bit of notation before we jump into
the proof
um
you've seen these uh notations before
just uh as a reminder so we're gonna
note uh denote um via p
the the matrix corresponding to the
transition curl and this is uh the
entries of these p are
um
sa
and the s s prime
which uh the the entry s a
uh s prime denotes the probability of
transitioning to s prime considering we
started in s and took action a this is
just the transition kernel
and then
p pi
is the transition probability
corresponding to policy pi this is a
number of actions
a number of states by number of actions
number of states so this is
basically a probability transition
between sa and sa a prime under policy
pi
okay
uh and just a reminder
under this notation
the the bellman
equation can be
written in matrix form as we've seen
before in policy evaluation
okay
so having this in mind
um
let's uh let's start the proof
um first thing we're going to do is
look
at
this quantity that we call gain which is
the performance of policy
um
at iteration k plus one versus the
policy at iteration k
so between two uh consecutive iterations
of uh approximate policy iteration where
uh where
we have two policies at these um at this
iterations and we're saying like how
much better is policy at k plus one with
respect to
uh the policy at
um
iteration k
okay and
first we're gonna um
try to say something about this quantity
and then we're gonna relate this
quantity with the the thing that we're
actually interested in which is the the
performance with respect to the optimal
policy
okay
so the the gain as defined uh
here is just the difference between
these uh consecutive
evaluation of
two consecutive
uh
iterations of policy uh
approximate policy iteration
and this is just um rewriting
the the above equation just
using that the fixed point of
operators
pi k and pi k
plus 1 are the value function
corresponding to these evaluations
okay
and then we're gonna do um we're gonna
add and subtract a couple of terms there
okay this might sound a bit um
or might look a bit scary at this point
but it's it's just adding up subtraction
um and it does have a
um
it does make sense in in terms of
we always do this this kind of procedure
just varying one term at the time
uh so if you look at the the first
equation here um 17 we are uh keeping
the operator fix but we're
uh varying the argument
uh in the next equation again we're
keeping the operator fixed but we're
changing the argument uh now um
in the in the next equation we are
changing the operator but keeping the
argument fixed and then the last one
we're keeping the operator fixed between
these two and changing the the argument
so usually
that's the kind of um
relationships that that we're gonna have
because we're gonna exploit the the
properties of these operators
okay
so i've just
written uh
exactly what we had in the previous
slide and we're gonna unpack this terms
okay let's look at the first
term here
this
this
is going to be r
we're just uh unpacking the definition
of these bellman operators
plus
gamma
and
sorry
two plus one
minus r plus gamma pi
plus one
at
okay
and uh we can see that the r there
goes uh goes away and what we're left
with is gamma
pi k plus 1
and
the difference between these policies
and this is what we called gain
okay
and similarly we can do the same trick
for this this equation and this would be
now
the r's again simplify
and we have
p
pi k plus 1
and the difference between
this
which we called um
ek
which is the
uh approximation error at iteration k
uh we're gonna skip this next turn
because
this one has a very similar um
expression as the ones which you we've
just seen because the operator is the
same
again things simplify and we get the
gamma
p
pi k
and
difference between these two and again
these are as before in the notation it's
minus
um
the approximation error that we incurred
at the iteration um
k uh just just a bit of uh notation
e k
we've denoted
this um
the difference between uh the evaluation
uh of the policy pi k and the estimate
uh qk
but not the norm of that
this this has a sign kind of thing
okay
the last term that that we have here is
this one and this one where um
we're actually not gonna do anything but
say that this is greater or equal than
zero
and
this is because
um
this policy
pi k plus 1 is the greedy
with respect to
uh this uh
um
q uh qk
which means that
the uh evaluation operator there is
actually the
optimality the one um
application of the belmont optimality
operator and this is less
greater than equal than any
application of any other policy
okay hopefully you are able to to follow
that if not uh just stop the video and
go over it but these are um
exactly the same equations but repeat it
in the in the slide
okay
and again this
this particular inequality
you can unpack it explicitly if you want
to convince yourself of that but the
argument we we've just
done is uh is sufficient
okay
so um
we
the only thing that we're gonna do now
is uh basically upper bound this
by
this um
so because
we're gonna replace this term with zero
um this is an upper bound and we're just
going to
plug in the the terms that the
simplification of the terms that we just
had here
okay
this is just rewriting
okay and
uh rewriting a bit
by
noticing that the gain
k appears both on the
right hand side and the left hand side
and collecting those terms we reach this
final expression
um by
bounding the the gain at iteration k
okay
so
um this is the statement that we've just
proven uh let's see
a couple of implications
so this gain is really how much your
policy the quality of the policy that
you derive
has improved from one iteration to to
the other
so
the first thing to notice is that
if e k
which is the approximation error
is
by definition uh here is um the gap
between the actual evaluation of policy
pi k
and
our approximation of that
so if that is zero
which means you have perfect evaluation
at
policy k
that thing is zero so uh what we're
getting is that the gain at iteration k
is greater
or equal than zero which means that the
pulse the quality of the policy at the
iteration k plus one is greater or equal
than the uh policy
uh the quality of the policy at
iteration um
k
which is exactly what we've proven
before in terms of the greedy
improvement step being um
an actual improvement step
guaranteed improvement step over the the
whole state space now
um
if this term is
different than 0
either
larger or
smaller than zero this is a vector so uh
some of the entries might be uh positive
some of them might be negative um
depending on your approximation so can
this gain uh be zero be
zero or uh negative
which would mean that
the at least in some states the policy
at
um iteration k plus one
actually is worse than the policy at
iteration k so
fortunately under under approximation
that's that can happen
um
and this is a very simple example just
to give you an intuition where things
can go wrong
so this is a simple mdp three states
we have uh plus one rewards every time
we transition at the end of this uh
chain
uh the action space is left and right
the fully deterministic
uh and where
uh let's say at iteration um k the
policy that we're uh evaluating
is uh always going right
okay
so if we if you if we evaluate this
policy the the value function
um q pi k associated with that
is is as follows
so um you can
you can convince yourself that um at
least
in the terminal state if if we're in
state uh s1 s2 and
taking action
1 which is exiting to this plus 1 reward
then we get the the reward the
plus one
if not if you're in
a state
as zero
um and you're taking action um
one which is going to s2 you uh
basically have a zero reward plus
gamma is 0.9 here
so
0 plus 0.9 and the value at this state
which is 0.9
uh the same for
s1 we're taking one step with
reward zero but
then we're discounting by 0.9 this
already discounted value of 0.9
now for
action
2 this is
a bit more complicated
we start with s1 so if you're in s1 and
take
action a2 you're gonna transition to
this terminal status and uh get uh
reward one
now
if you are in uh
state s0
and
take action
uh a2 you're going to transition to s1
and then
you're still going to follow
this is evaluating this deterministic
policy of always going right so we make
one transition
according to
a a2 we transition to s1 and then from
s1 we continue according to policy pi k
and the
according to policy pi k we're just
gonna
go right
uh which means that we're we're making a
step we we
transition to to s1 and then uh
basically we're just discounting this
value
again because in s1 we're not actually
transitioning
to the the end state there we're not
actually exiting because we are
executing a policy that will get us in
the opposite direction
okay
hopefully that's clear
now consider um instead of having this
full
evaluation of policy pi k
consider an approximation
um
for different reasons you might have
either a functional class or um
based on samples you get this this
approximation and
i've just made up some values that are
you know fairly close to what the
the evaluation would be and uh it's it
it also maintains the you know um
the relationship between the uh the
action values
at least within within the same action
okay so it it's a reasonable
approximation now if you take the greedy
with respect to this approximation
to this evaluation
then you get a policy
pi k plus 1
which is this
so
this is just reading out from
our approximation
what what am i going to do in s1 well i
look at the value of these two actions
uh obviously uh a2 is better i'm going
to take that one uh the same in
s
0 um i look at the the
the values of these actions
the one corresponding to a1 is better so
i'm gonna take that one
and in um s2
i'm gonna i'm looking again at the
approximate values uh here and i see
that a2 in this case is better than uh
than a1 so the the induced policy is uh
um
is the one depicted here
okay
so
let's now
see uh this this new policy at iteration
k plus one if we if i were to actually
evaluate
how good that policy is
what
what would that evaluation be
and this is the evaluation for the the
policy that we've just computed as
greedy with respect to the approximation
that that we had
and this one
um because of the cycle there
going back and forth between those uh
those states actually has this value
function
which you can see that if you compare
the the
value of a policy at uh policy pi k and
the the one at
uh
policy at the k plus one you can see
that even state by state these things
are either equal
or
the policy at the
iteration k plus 1 is actually worse
uh in this state
um
in this state in this state
so actually this is an extreme example
of uh of what i wanted to illustrate in
the game being the negative that in all
of the k in all of the states um and
actions
uh the the gain is act uh either zero or
negative
in most situation you would have a mix
of these where in some cases it will be
an improvement but in some states and
actions it it can actually be negative
so it's not
it's not under approximation it's not
necessarily a strict improvement
over the policy we had at the previous
iteration and there is where the the
problems
with the uh with convergence and with
you know the the monotonic improvement
of these is this policies uh occurs
okay
okay
um this was a bit of a detour but i
think it was it's it's good to to have
an intuition of what happens from one
iteration to to the other and
why this fails under
um potentially fails under uh
approximation so let's go back to the
proof
and actually go for the term that we are
actually interested in in bounding which
is the quality of the policy after k
iteration with respect to the optimal
value function
okay
uh we're gonna denote by lk
exactly the difference between the
optimal value function and
the
quality of the policy at the iteration k
note that this thing is always
positive
uh because the by definition the
the value of the optimal policy is um
greater than the
value of any other policy and this is
this is not an approximation this is an
actual evaluation of the policy at the
iteration k
okay
so we're gonna start with just the
definition
uh we're gonna do a similar thing that
we did before
introducing the the bellman operators
and um
using the fact that um
both of these
value functions are
um
fixed points of
the
expectation
operator
of
pi k plus 1 and the
fixed point of the
evaluation
the expectation
evaluator with respect to the optimal
policy
okay and then we're gonna do exactly
what we did before which is uh introdu
like
uh introduce a couple of uh
of terms so adding and subtracting a few
of these terms
so just
just convince yourself that this thing
and this thing goes um
simplify the same this one and this one
this one and this one this one and this
one and again the same recipe uh as
before we're just changing one thing at
a time so the the the operator state is
the same the argument is different
again the operator stays the same
argument is different
the
the operator changes here
uh and so on so forth
okay
and
we're gonna do very similar thing that
we did before and
basically bound
uh all the terms that
that we've uh all these um
differences
um we're gonna uh either spell them out
or
uh bound them uh in this case by zero
okay
the the argument goes exactly as we did
before they are uh uh they're just uh
rewriting what these differences are
okay
so by collecting uh the terms here
and again this uh
this particular inequality
is
a
follows the same argument as we had
before because um
this
operator
is uh the greedy with respect to
uh q
k so
pi k plus 1 is by definition the greedy
with respect to
the approximation
q k
so that means this operator is actually
the one step
optimality operator
applied to
qk
okay
so this one is always
better or it's always greater than any
kind of policy there
so any any other
evaluation operator applied to
qk can't be better
okay
so we're just uh we're just gonna
rewrite uh or
all of the terms that we in group all of
the terms that we had uh here
um
and uh we're gonna
now uh expand we had the term here in
terms of the the gain
at the iteration k and we've previously
upper bounded this by this expression
so from 27 to 28 we're just plugging in
the bound that we've previously proven
uh for gk
and we're just
bringing the terms together and
rewriting a couple of uh stuff
and a couple of things simplify from
29 to
30.
okay
and uh um
now
sorry um
as
uh
as k tends to infinity
um
then we can
uh
we can introduce the limb soup of this
quantity so we have uh lk and lk plus
one uh in in
one side of the equation and the the
other side of the equation uh in
asymptotic regime as uh as k tends to
infinity this will uh become just this
term
and then
um basically by rewriting
we we have this expression so this term
all of this term here appears in the
limb soup here
and the last thing that that we're going
to do is
we're gonna take the l infinity norm
with respect to this equation this is
just rewriting uh what was on the on the
other slide
okay and when you when we take that
we have a couple of terms there that
that
will simplify
um
so in particular if you look at this
term uh this
um
fairly ugly term in uh in equation 37
this actually simplifies to
being upper bounded
by um
one plus gamma
over one minus gamma plus one this is
using the fact that uh all of these
matrixes uh
p a pi
uh for
pi equals uh
pi k plus one or pi k or
the the optimal
policy all of them are stochastic uh
matrixes
where the l infinity norm of all of
these is one
okay
and that is uh that is it for the for
the proof
if you
uh rewrite basically this uh
this term you get exactly what the
statement of the the theorem uh says
so this is uh ek was exactly uh the
the approximation error that we incur at
the iteration k and this term just
simplifies to this
okay
last thing we're going to do here is
look at the concrete instance of of this
algorithm
and we're gonna actually look at an
algorithm that you've seen before
uh
namely td lambda with uh
a linear under linear approximation
important to note at this point that
this algorithm at least in the form that
i describe it here
will just implement the policy valuation
step
in an approximate policy iteration
loop
so it's it's just one of the
steps that you have to do at each
iteration k in this approximate policy
iteration
it's a policy evaluation
this is
mainly to show how one could reason
under function approximator about the
errors you incur at this evaluation step
because we've seen from the the previous
result that the quality at least in the
limit of
the policy that you're gonna get at
iteration k as k tends to infinity as
compared to the optimal uh value
function is bounded by how the
errors at the at each iteration
as case goes to uh to infinity uh behave
so
keeping those errors
as small as possible in the policy uh
evaluation uh case
will mean that that bound is tighter and
tighter which means that with respect to
the optimal uh value function you're
losing less and less so uh in in the
best case scenario if that
if those error are zero then you will
converge to the optimal value function
so this is just a an attempt at uh
saying
under
you know the
normal scenario where we're using
function approximator and we're using
something like td learning how can we
reason about the errors that we incur in
this procedure
okay
so uh we start with the linear
functional space
and
remember that the tdr
under this approximation is
defined as in equation 37
and then the parameter update
w
at each step after each tdr
uh is updated
with the magnitude of the tdr in the
direction of phi
s t a t uh previously i think you've
seen this update for just the value
function not the um
state action value function and this phi
would be
um just a function of the state and i
think you've denoted it as xd
okay
well
under this um under this
paradigm
um
this this algorithm actually has nice
properties so under the normal
conditions on uh of the
learning rate here
uh
satisfying these conditions
the the sum of them being infinite and
the the square of them being finite then
this
procedure
converges to
um
its limit um denoted here by
uh w star
which is not approximating the optimal
value function it's just the annotation
for the fixed point
and
uh all
all of this procedure is trying to
approximate uh the value of some policy
pi
the one we are computing the td errors
with respect to
and uh furthermore
it has been shown in the same paper the
sickness and panroi
that
the
the approximation error that we're gonna
be incurring by using td in this uh
uh in in this formulation is bounded
by one
minus
gamma lambda
over one minus
gamma
and this term is basically the best that
you can do
in this functional space
with respect to
to this norm so this is the
uh
the point in
f that is the closest
to
the value function you're trying to
approximate
the closest to the approximation so this
is uh really saying that if
i were
to know this
evaluation in advance
then
if i were to just represent it
in this functional uh
functional space f this is the the
closest that i can get in terms of
approximation
and
the whole expression is just saying that
if i am
doing this um
temporal difference
learning under mild conditions
i'm going to be bounded by
basically the
best way of representing the the value
function that i'm interested in
this this might not be exactly uh the
this this point the best approximator to
uh q pi
but is very close to it
okay
um
just a couple of um
you know breaking down uh the the
statement as as we usually do
um
one is
uh you can
lambda is a parameter in td lambda so um
uh
one thing that we can ask is for which
lambda is this upper bound
the tightest which means that we lose we
are guaranteed to lose the least and it
turns out if you're
eyeballing that or maximizing over that
is that for
lambda equals 1 which corresponds to the
monte carlo estimate
this
this band is tighter and
i'll let you reason why that would be
the case
okay uh the the other question that
might come to mind is
what if the
um
the value that we're trying to
uh to evaluate
the
the value of the policy that we're
trying to evaluate this q pi is actually
representable in our um
space of uh
hypothesis class
well then the
this part of the equation actually is
zero which means
that
uh
q
um
w star which is the the point of
convergence of the the the previous
algorithm is actually two pi so
this is nice
because we're saying that if my
um
the the function that i'm trying to
represent is part of my uh
my functional class then i'm guaranteed
with this algorithm to converge to that
okay um now the question becomes if this
is not the case if
q pi is not
representable in uh
our hypothesis space
then in general um
well we won't recover q pi
but more more general than that the the
fixed point we converge to this um
uh q
uh
w uh star
is
generally
not the best approximation that we can
get
uh in this function of class which is
exactly what this this term says
okay
okay that is uh it uh for today i'm
gonna just do a quick summary uh now of
the the two paradigms in approximate
dynamic programming that with that we've
uh we've seen today
first let's start with the approximate
value uh iteration
so uh we've proven this result where as
a reminder um
pi n
is the the policy that we're getting at
iteration n
of this procedure
now some lessons that we've learned uh
in general uh the conversion is not
guaranteed depends highly on the
approximation
but in practice a lot of the algorithm
that we've seen and we use in practice
look at all the instantiations that we
had at the at the end of this
section
um
seems to point that in practice this is
generally well behaved
how how do we control uh how good the
the policy that we're getting is well
the the way to control uh this is to
control the approximate uh the
approximation error and there are two
sources of error the estimation
by a sampling so we don't have access to
the true
belmont operator and then there's the
approximation
coming from the
the function class that you we are using
we saw that
although all of these results are in
terms of the l infinity norm and if we
were to optimize with respect to that we
would get the safe algorithm in the
sense of this being a
full contraction operator and having a
unique fixed point
for more
efficient optimization we usually
substitute this l infinity norm with
something like an l2 with respect to
some distribution
usually that will be the stationary
distribution
with respect to the policy that that
we're following okay
um
note that
the convergence point is not always
q star especially if q star is not
representable in the
function class
and
even if that is the case if q star is
representable in the functional class
that is not enough
uh just remind yourself of the the
example that we had where
really the the inside there is that all
of the intermediate errors kind of have
to be zero in order for that to happen
it's it's not it's not exactly necessary
it's
the better way of saying it is that um
there might be
uh
errors at different points in that the
iteration um
process that can introduce
errors that cannot be cannot be washed
away
or at least we can't say anything
um because this is kind of the worst
case scenario we're maximizing over all
these errors it might still be possible
to uh to converge to a q star it's just
um
at least based on this
bound we're not guaranteed to to do that
if we are incurring uh any kind of error
at any of the
intermediate iterations
okay and then
what we've just seen is approximate
policy
iteration
and we've proven this result um
uh
a couple of lessons again in general
convergences uh is not guaranteed but
again in practice this seems to be well
behaved
its popularity is not as great as the
other paradigm
just because
it does have uh this
inner loop this uh procedure of policy
evaluation which is in itself is a is a
problem of its uh its own you you've
seen the
i guess the the first lecture on uh
model three prediction that that alone
can be an iterative procedure itself so
it's not it's it's not easy to
usually it's not easy to evaluate a
policy so this being just this
side
inside step of another interactive
procedure
means that
in practice
it's not it's not used as often
okay
um again
the the statement really
the only thing that says is that if we
can control this errors e ek actually
the the um
l infinity norm of these these errors
then uh
we are able to control the the quality
of the end result
and at the same as before there are two
sources of error
sampling and functional crass
approximation
for
we haven't gone uh
really that much into this uh example
but uh
uh for efficient uh optimization again
we do the same thing of uh trading in
the l infinity norm to a much more
behave well behave the approximation uh
prob optimization problem in the l2 uh
norm and this is usually
now with respect to the
stationary distribution of the policy
that we're trying to evaluate right now
a different way of saying is
this is that we are safe on policy
um
this is just the
distribution of states
uh that
acting in the environment with respect
to the policy that we're trying to
evaluate pi i in this
case
will will induce
okay
and
again depending on the the function
class and the couple of mild condition
we can obtain convergence but the
convergence point is not always
um
q
q
q star or even q pi in the
policy evaluation case and
moreover we haven't touched upon this
but it is known that the convergent
point for
approximate policy iteration may not be
unique in the sense of
this uh this expression actually can
have the behavior of um
stabilizing uh like going down in terms
of the
the error and stabilizing around the
band uh
around the around the point it's still
bounded by this term but it might
oscillate back and forth around that uh
that point
okay
that is it for today
any questions that you might have please
post on moodle or come to the q a
session thank you for your time